So one of the first things I want to do is add a button right
here that plays some audio.
Let me drag out the Utility area and
then go find the button, and then drag that on to the canvas here.
Now, I'm going to change the image of this button in a little bit.
But before I do that, I want to think about where I am going to
write the code that will execute when I press this button.
In essence, where do I write the action for
this button using the control+drag technique?
Let's think about how we did for the stop button in the previous scene.
I am going to select this scene and then go to the Assistant Editor.
So you may recall that we control+dragged from this stop button to this file,
viewcontroller.swift and created an action called stopAudio.
So what we need to do now is create a new viewcontroller for
this second scene in our app.
All right, to do that I will first manage some screen space by going back to
the standard editor.
Then I will go to the File menu at the top, click on New, and
then create a new File.
Here, under iOS on the left, I will select a Cocoa Touch Class, and
then click Next.
I will call this class, PlaySoundsViewController.
Now, this is going to be a subclass of UIViewController,
because we want to inherit metrics like view did load, etcetera.
Our language is still Swift, and I will hit Next.
And I will save this new class in the same folder as my app and hit Create.
All right, so we now have a new file called PlaySoundsViewController.swift with
a class by the same name inside it.
So, the next thing to do here is to go back to the storyboard, and
connect this second scene in our app here to the new file that we just made.
So I will select this second scene and then open the Utilities tray.
In here under Identity Inspector, you will notice that the cut and
view controller is this guy, UIViewController.
I can substitute this with PlaySoundsViewController, and
as I start typing Escort auto completes it for me.
All right, so let's make the action for this button now.
I can go to the Assistant editor and on the left here, I see my storyboard.
And on the right I see the view controller that this scene is associated with,
which is the new file we created, PlaySoundsViewController.swift.
If I go to my first scene, you will notice that he view controller on
the right hand side of the screen changes which is ViewController.swift.
So I can hop back and forth between my first scene and the second scene in
the app, and the view controller for it changes automatically.
The reason why that happens is because we have this automatic setting
selected over here.
All right, now we can create an action for
this button in this new ViewController.